Hey Doc, what's H. Pylori?
And how do I get rid of it?
How did it start?
Well, he'll go back to Pylori is a bacterial infection.
It's actually the most common bacterial infection
in the world.
And it is normally a part of our microbiota in a balance.
When he gets out of balance and it starts growing,
many times it initiates in the stomach.
And most commonly, it's from a deficiency
in the production of hydrochloric acid.
So when we start with adding hydrochloric acid
to our diet with each meal, that could be very helpful.
Maybe it needs to start with apple cider vinegar.
I have a whole portal call on our website
that you can look at.
But H. Pylori can creep into the stomach
and grow unabated and cause ulcers in the stomach,
the esophagus, and the intestinal tract.
It can also go beyond the stomach.
It into the blood vessels.
It is one of the top causes of cardiovascular disease,
which is still the top rated cause of death
in the United States.
So it's something that we need to deal with.
H. Pylori can cause skin issues.
H. Pylori is a number one cause of stomach cancer
and it can be cause of other cancers as well.
So it's something that we need to deal with
because it causes gut issues and systemic issues.
Look on our website for more on H. Pylori.